oh wait wait ah there we go alright guys
welcome back to parka Tex and today I'll
be trying to tackle Nova Labs now the
description if this scenario is that it
was the set for some kind of sci-fi
movie and now it's up for sale for a
theme park which is a really cool trend
actually there are lots of theme parks
in the world which are kind of based on
that premise we've got something like
the Hollywood style parks of Universal
and Disney as well also some Italian
park there's actually lots of variations
on this but sci-fi is definitely a new
take on that genre but in any case the
goals are again a bit of a step up from
the last one we've got an optional goal
that I'm probably not gonna reach we can
be sure of that by now I think but let's
just get started on the park now I said
in the end of the last episode then I
wanted to try and see if I could maybe
pull a steampunk theme out of this
general sci-fi theme of the map but that
said actually what is what is my
entrance so this is the actual park I
suppose yeah it looks that way
so it's really large actually Wow so
this is where the people are coming from
and yeah I'm I'm very curious actually
what kind of scenery stuff I have
because honestly it just kind of depends
on what week gets ya so all of this is
really the sci-fi stuff and some more
sci-fi stuff over here but it looks like
we're not getting any of the the gears
and cogs and stuff like that so yeah
honestly forget about steampunk that's
probably not gonna work maybe I'll try
that one other day the reason that I was
thinking about it is because I saw some
other people do it in some of their
sandbox parks and the game has amazing
steampunk pieces lots of little gears
and cogs and spiraling coils and things
that are really interesting and fun to
use also some pipe works even but it
looks like we're not gonna get any of
that stuff in this map not too much of
an issue because I can also just try to
work around a sci-fi theme the
only thing there is that honestly this
is a theme which I'm not that good at so
I'm gonna try and get out of my comfort
zone a little bit on this park the
second thing we should probably look at
is the money we've got quite a bit
that's good and very sci-fi ish writes
honestly some of this stuff really fits
into the theme and really good coasters
as well I'm almost surprised that we got
the steel coaster right off the bat so
that's really nice I don't know if I
want to go for that or a spinning
coaster I'm not the biggest fan of the
powered coaster even if it does fit the
theme quite well but it's I'm definitely
going to start off with one of these two
and then the powered coaster could
probably be the family-oriented ride of
the park because you'll often find that
you know when a park doesn't have the
sort of typical family coaster that you
normally see they all have a powered
coaster or they'll have both but they're
definitely in the same kind of category
but yeah it looks like we don't have too
much stuff so I definitely want to
research the thrill rides get a team to
spend maybe 100 bucks a month and
actually quite importance is the food
okay so we're we're decent in this park
because we've got a vending machine
which sells chips but I think
researching stalls first might actually
be a really good idea I've gotten a lot
of tips from people also that I should
look more into researching some of the
shops just because on some of the later
scenarios you'll get some maps where you
don't start off with either food or
drinks at the beginning of scenario and
you really have to make sure that you're
selling both of these just to be able to
you know make your guests stay alive
probably so that's pretty important so
I'm just gonna research that and try to
get started in the meantime so I have no
idea what I'm gonna build
but I'm just gonna start building some
stuff so let's go all right now before I
get into the rest of the park I wanted
to change the existing scenery a little
bit now the limitations of the scenario
are that you're not allowed to remove
anything that's already there but a
little bit of a life hack there is that
that doesn't count for recoloring stuff
so you can recolor
anything you want so that's also what I
ended up doing as much as I think the
existing colors worked fine as they were
and we're maybe actually a little bit
better considering the theme I like to
make everything a little bit more
colorful and have different kinds of
details in there so I decided to change
the colors a little bit and add some
stuff to it as well and I think that
actually kind of reflects the general
way in which I'm approaching this park I
just hit my pop filter as I often do I
hope I don't make too much of a noise
doing that actually but yeah basically I
want to do this a bit differently than I
normally do things normally I try to
work on a very realistic a very theme
based way and try to build everything to
be very much based on real life
theme parks or cities or cultures etc
but in this case I mean we've got the
sci-fi theme or somewhere in outer space
well presumably we're in some kind of
studio that's been transformed into a
theme park but it's all a little bit
more fantastical so I'm not actually
using any references in this case and I
want to go a little bit out of my
comfort zone and just go kind of crazy
with this park I was initially thinking
of trying to stick with the theme that
you get from the existing buildings but
I think it's better to maybe you know
make sure that everything can fit into
that same theme but at the same time use
this scenario as an opportunity to go a
bit crazy with some of the elements in
in the game and just experiment a lot so
that's what I'm gonna do and maybe not
everything is gonna stick I'm really
just gonna do whatever I can come up
with at any given moment so it's all
gonna be a little bit strange but I do
like doing it this way I think for me
it's just more fun to try it this way
and it's also something that I don't get
to do all the time so over here for
instance I am building a very small food
court and it really is small because
it's just drinks actually and then
there's a vending machine somewhere but
I'm researching drinks in the meantime
so that should be fine but yeah I
thought it would be nice to experiment
with some of these round corners peace
is to create a kind of pattern above
this whole area to make everything look
a little bit more interesting but it's
just one of these little things where I
thought it would be fun to mess with it
a little bit so yeah I'm not gonna to
strictly make sure that everything fits
together in this Park and it's just
gonna be quite a bit of a chaotic mess I
would almost say that it's a bit
inspired by wallaby Holland perhaps not
in a sense of scenery but it's
definitely a park that in recent years
has been focusing a lot on getting
different bright colors and these lots
of very different areas in the park and
that's sort of I don't know that sort of
way of looking at things I would like to
try to adopt for this park a little bit
now over here is the first roller
coaster I decided to go for the spinning
coaster in the end just because it's a
bit more cheap than the steel looping
coaster and it's something for me to
kind of base the layouts of the park
around as well and this might sound a
little bit weird but I kind of struggle
with trying to get a decent organic
feeling layouts in a park it's something
that when I play planet coaster for
instance I tend to experiment with a lot
I tend to really try to layout my parks
as much as I can try to imagine where I
want to play certain things and how
everything's gonna flow in my head and
only after I know exactly what
everything's gonna look like in the end
do I actually dare to start working on
stuff but in this case it's just
scenarios so I'm doing everything on the
fly and I always like to have a bit of a
guideline as to where things are gonna
go and how the general flow of the
layouts of the park is gonna be and in
some scenarios you pretty much get that
handed to you so in mystic os's or
Victoria Lake you very much have these
park layouts like the natural terrain
just sort of helps you to find your way
I think especially if you have these
kind of lakes to follow or these sort of
valleys to build in but in this case
it's a completely flat valley so
there's nothing really to base my my
general flow of the park on so I like
having this spinning coaster as
something not quite as a centerpiece but
something to work around and that's also
why the layouts is a little bit you know
meandering through the park I was
initially inspired by dragon's fury I
think that's when it's called in
Chessington World of Adventures I don't
know if that's the name of the coaster
I'm not quite sure but they're spinning
coaster also has that way of moving
around the park and not just being
limited to one location and I thought
that's quite nice for a spinning coaster
and a good way to provide some sort of
context something to build around as
well because obviously I can't build
underneath the coaster so the park
layout is just gonna sort of follow the
layouts of the spinning coaster here
which is also fun because it gives you a
lot of interaction between the coaster
and the various rides and paths and
stuff like that that's gonna be built
around it now over here I just built
that a motion simulator which I thought
always interesting because it's built on
top of one of these buildings that you
get with the scenario so I wasn't
allowed to remove anything about that
building but I thought it would be fun
to add something on top of it just to
make things a little bit more
interesting and the motion simulator is
a tiny flat ride that sits on such a
small footprint that it can just kind of
work on that little overhang over there
where you can see it looking out over
the paths as you're walking on the paths
themselves so I think that was quite
nice also decided to do a little bit of
lighting and yeah everything is gonna be
pretty colorful I do have to say also
one of these things where it's a bit
more different than what I usually like
to do because I'm almost too careful
always with colors trying to not mix too
many different colors at the same time
but in this case I just want to try and
get all kinds of different colors out
there also to sort of prevents the whole
gritty industrial colorless look that
it's a bit of a trap almost I feel of
sci-fi builds
and I should I should also say actually
I didn't really look up any inspiration
now this was a question which I got on
the last video and this is something
that I've talked about before into my
other series but given that this series
has a lot of new viewers or people are
just here for parka text I'm pretty down
to talk about this again so basically I
don't really read books or articles or
anything about the styles of
architecture that I build like a lot of
it is just sort of winging it looking up
stuff on the internet looking at piss
pictures for reference or inspiration
that said whenever I do a certain style
I tend to go on a bit of a Google spree
and Wikipedia spree to get some of the
basics down but I'm not really that
knowledgeable like everything that I
talk about in a lot of my videos a lot
of that isn't you know just that I'm I
know everything about all kinds of
different architectures and cultures but
it's just because I tend to look up that
stuff just before I move into recording
that video but that's basically my
process I decide on a certain theme just
because out of some kind of interest
that I have and then I just research it
a little bit before I move into it but
in this case since this is some kind of
a sci-fi outerspace theme there's not
really anything that I have to base it
on so for a bit of inspiration actually
went back to an old roller coaster
country build of mine called protons and
some of that stuff will definitely come
back later in this video for example
it's just in the idea of using these
different colored trees and very gritty
industrial but colorful style of the
park I think for me Protoss was the
first time when I started experimenting
very much with an outerspace sci-fi
theme in the context of a roller coaster
with lots of colored foliage and random
details everywhere and following that
general same style for me is something
that helped me along this scenario
now I'm running behind a little bit
again so over here we've got the sitting
sitting area I guess it's not too many
ventures but there's a few but it was
much more or less actually an excuse to
try that path pattern with the different
purple colors and then again using the
roof cornice pieces just for an
interesting pattern I think those things
are kind of similar to what I believe
you call a mandala I'm not quite sure
but it's one of those like round doodle
paintings that a lot of adults now do as
a coloring activity whatever one of
those round interesting little pattern
things it's it's something like that I
suppose it's just fun to mess around
with these things until you get
something that looks interesting I think
one of the things which I do like about
doing this kind of scenario is that for
me I can think of it outside of the box
I whoops yeah I hit my pop filter again
I have but yeah I can think a little bit
more outside of the box because I
usually tend to do things quite safely
and also just use some of the pieces
very differently for me in general one
of the most important things whether it
would be in rollercoaster can through
your planet coaster park text or any of
these sort of creative games is not to
look at pieces and then think of what
you should use them for but really just
to come up with something you want to
build and then see whatever pieces can
help you build that so I never really
want to scroll through the items looking
for my next thing to build and I think
that's a trap that a lot of people fall
into you just kind of scroll through the
menu you know looking at what you have
kind of thinking well what can I
actually do anything with and for me it
honestly works a lot better to just
think of random ideas of what I want to
try building somewhere and then
scrolling through the different items to
see what can help me build that and I
mean that's generally how I ended up
coming up with weird strategies like
using chimney pieces to build pillars
and things like that it's not that you
have to think out of the box per se but
just having
a certain goal in mind and then looking
at the pieces for me at least and I
think this goes for a lot of people
though it can really help to use the
pieces in different creative ways and in
ways that they might not be supposed to
be used which is always good thing I
think so yeah that's my strategy for
using scenery pieces in creative games
is almost like my strategy in a
supermarket honestly looking up first
what I want to get and honestly when I'm
in a store I just run right away to
whatever I oh I need to get whatever
item get everything straight away and
leave the store again
I guess that's that's honestly a good
analogy for me in in the whole like item
menus in creative video games as well
god I I swear I just came up with that
but I think actually kind of works in
any case some of the scenery over here
is quite simple I decided to add a small
food court ish area with a trap building
over there just because it fills up the
space quite nicely
and as a final thing of this part of the
time-lapse I decided to add this
Gravitron I think that's what it's
called very sci-fi and looking right of
course and just slap some weird scenery
around it I'm actually not too sure
about how well these things worked out
but I just decided to build some weird
stuff around it and see what sticks more
or less and also a little bit of shade
because we are in the desert it's over
all over here and I don't know it
doesn't look like the like the climate
is very hot but still something that I
want to try and feature here here and
there at least in any case let's get
back into a quick real-time section and
see how the park is doing now this
little park is definitely not as
profitable as I was hoping it to be the
top spin over here is making some decent
ish money the Gravitron is making
alright money sort of comparable motion
simulator is not even doing as good as I
expected and the spinning coaster over
here that's that's a me
yoga right so actually this park is a
kind of a fail its stagnating and if I
keep going like this it's definitely not
going to end up too well that said I'm
not gonna build this up like some kind
of dramatic YouTube video we don't have
that kind of narrative here it's gonna
be fine anyway I just need to keep in
mind that I'm not gonna be able to
finish the park like this so I'm
definitely gonna have to take a loan and
build something much more thrilling to
attract more guests besides I don't even
have a staff room yet so that's also a
disaster waiting to happen I need to fix
that as soon as possible and then
there's a this stuff like the
thunderstorms which makes it even more
difficult so I'm gonna try as soon as
possible to get a decent loan now all of
these have pretty high monthly fees as
well unfortunately so whatever I build
is gonna have to save the park so of
course it's gonna hopefully have to look
pretty good but it's also going to have
to be pretty intense and I mean when I
think about its I honestly need to stop
researching shops because we've got the
hot dogs now I'm gonna get the burgers
what I really need I think is probably
going to be a coaster actually no maybe
I can research thrill rides and finish
the coaster selection with a steel
coaster and a powered coaster whatever
happens I'm definitely gonna have to
build the steel coaster next make it a
good thrilling ride to make about a
thousand dollars profit a month or
something like that or this park is just
gonna crash and burn so yeah let's go
back into the time-lapse and try to fix
this mess now before I talk a little bit
more about this coaster I want to give a
bit of an announcements as to why it's
taken me so long to record this episode
because right here there's a small time
skip of about three weeks from when you
just hurt me to when you're hearing me
right now basically I got sick then it
was a holiday so I traveled around for a
little bit and then when when I got back
and I wanted to record some stuff I got
sick again
it's not too bad I've been able to
record some time lapse but my voice
wasn't really in a state where I felt
comfortable recording any commentaries
for it and to be quite honest it still
isn't release so I'm gonna edit out the
cuffs out of this recording but if you
can hear that my voice isn't what it's
usually like then that's the reason I'm
still going through a cold but I really
want to record this right now because
I've been getting so many questions from
people as to why it's taken me so long
to release this new episode but yeah
that's basically the reason I've had
this time lapse right here waiting for
me to record over it and I just couldn't
find the time to do it so I'm sorry
about that it's a bit of my own
management problems as well because I
should really have a sort of backup plan
or some kind of backup videos at hand
but I really don't I record this stuff
as I go which works fine as long as I am
able to record videos but I wasn't
really for the past time so yeah that's
what's going on don't dwell on that for
too much longer though but just so you
know that's why I sound like this so
this coaster itself let's talk about
that for a little bit so it's I think I
would suppose that it's say a premiere
inspired coaster
so premiere makes these L AM launch
coasters like mount freeze reverse blast
and also full throttle but that's a bit
of a more new gen thing but yeah it
makes these coasters and they kind of
look like this coaster in game even
though this coaster is the sort of in
universe Schwartzkopf looping coaster I
think the track style is very
reminiscent also of the premier launch
coasters so that was my starting points
for this one so it starts off with a
simple L AM launched into a top hat
which I that is a bit of a difference
because these coasters in real life
would be an LS M launch if I remember
correctly but yeah this start is a bit
inspired by coasters like King Decca or
well Top Thrill Dragster
but then it actually does something with
it so we get a bit apart where it just
kind of curves around this first launch
section then one really big airtime Hill
over the pathway and over the station
I wanted to add a little bit more
decoration to this as well because the
color scheme is quite simple it's just
black on black so I wanted to give it
some more touches to make it a bit more
interesting so we've got the red and
whites launch section and I think this
red and white sort of color scheme works
really well for these industrial looking
things I don't know when it sort of
became the code for dangerous things but
you know how our cables and chimneys
very often have these kinds of color
schemes so I like to slap this on to
industrial themed launch coasters so it
works for the launch section as well as
those supports towers which are at once
sort of the theming objects because I
think they look pretty neat but they're
also pretty necessary because the
supports disappeared because of the path
underneath it and I want actually return
to the colors because I think it's a bit
of a handy tip actually the paint brush
tool which you can see on the bottom
there next to the bulldozer actually
paints brushes a lot more than you might
expect so you can use it to paint the
track like I just did and give different
parts of track a different color but you
can also paint individual cars of
coasters for instance so you can
actually go home with the different
color options that you have with this
thing so yeah definitely one of my
favourite tools in the game and combined
with the pipette tool to color colors
from existing scenery and buildings it's
a super powerful tool so definitely
something to keep in mind there and for
the station I'm following a color
related approach which is very similar
to the rest of the park and I think it's
the one thing that sort of pulls the
park together so if you look at it from
a distance the main colors are all black
and gray and light gray very
nitty-gritty industrial kind of colors
but I'm trying to detail everything and
put these little elements everywhere
with all kinds of different colors like
orange and purple and blue and red to
make the park much more interesting on
the eye and I think that's also the one
thing that sort of pulls the pike
together and trying something new in
a single area but there's always this
sort of connecting trend of mostly dark
grayscale colors which are detailed with
different very bright color elements so
I think that's one thing that sort of
pulls the pie together even though it's
random and kind of all over the place so
over here I decided to make an indoor
cue line actually which is not something
you can really see I thought it would be
interesting to put something inside
there just for the heck of it
but it's it's not something that you can
see in a normal playthrough unless you
install mods where you can go into a
first-person perspective but for this
playthrough I'd like to keep the game
the game completely mod free just to
experience the campaign as you would in
a vanilla game also some of the mods do
break the game and they would make the
campaign easier and I don't want to do
that to myself but yeah I also thought
this Q line indoors would work quite
well because it looks a bit like an
industrial backlots building which is in
hindsight something that I think the
park needs more than I ended up doing it
because this is one of the few cases
where I did this just because in the end
the setting of this park is that it's
some kind of abandoned movie sites some
kind of sets for an alien landscape and
not actually a real alien landscape so
some of these backlog buildings help
sort of you know make that context very
clear and in the end I think I could
have done that much more because in the
end this is a super surrealistic and
alien looking park and much more out
there than all of the other scenarios so
far but that's also what I kind of like
about it it's it's not just about the
final you know outcome I also do want to
have some fun building it so this was a
nice opportunity to just go around and
mess with different things for every
single area of the park and some of it
works some of it didn't quite work as
well like this little sort of
centerpiece that always trying to build
here I wanted to have some kind of
spiraling centerpiece but given these
very edgy pieces it didn't really work
- well so I ended up going for something
really similar or something really
different I should say and I still don't
quite know what this thing is but it
looks pretty fancy and scientific or
something like that so yeah I'll keep
that in there and aside from that there
isn't too much to be done for this part
of the park just some finishing touches
around the coaster but I think it's a
good time to move on to the next coaster
because this scenario actually ended up
having a lot of really big coasters and
being basically a sandbox for trying out
different coaster layouts so yeah let's
check it out so the next coaster is
going to be a bnm floorless coaster and
i think this is the first one in the
playthrough so far it's not the first
bnm but these coasters are always quite
expensive and quite a major investments
not just in parsecs but in a real-life
context as well you usually just find
these things in really large rich parks
so I don't get to build these kinds of
coasters too often in scenarios either
it's more of a late-game coaster and in
this case I left my game running for a
little bit so there's a small-time skip
here just to get some more money but it
turns out that the coaster that I just
built made a lot more money than I
expected I think it's my most profitable
one so far in the beginning it was
pulling in $2,000 every month so I ended
up being a lot more rich than I expected
and with more money than I knew what to
do with so hence I decided to build this
floorless coaster to try and burn
through some of that money now this
layout particularly is inspired by hare
racer in Hong Kong's
ocean park which is one of my personal
favorite Flores coasters I should add to
that I haven't been on it myself it's
one of my favorites in terms of what
I've seen POV is for on the Internet
it looks super cool though it's based on
it's built on a cliff side next to the
ocean in Hong Kong it's really compact
but it still manages to do a lots of
different things with the layout it has
a super cool color scheme as well that I
ended up copying in a lot of my coasters
and yeah just overall a super cool ride
and I definitely want to travel to Hong
Kong
one day and when I do I should
definitely give that coaster a visit so
this the inspiration I think is mostly
visible in the mix of different elements
and the way that the layouts is shaped
with that curves the drop first into the
loop into the dive loop and then sort of
going back and forth with different
inversions until you're out of potential
energy and you just return to the
station or the break run I should say
and then that's the end of it now for
this station this time I decided to do
something a little bit different
although it's very similar to stations
that have built so far and I kind of
want to throw back to rollercoaster
tycoon 3 and I don't know how many of
you guys remember this but in the custom
scenery community of rollercoaster 3
there was this guy called stuck 71 I
believe and he made a few industrial
themed custom scenery sets one of them I
think was HDR 51 and HDR 71 which were
these hangars styled sets and these
hangar pieces look quite similar to the
the park tech pieces as well but what's
most striking is his SKR 91 set I think
that's what it's called it's it's years
ago but these were some of the most
popular custom scenery sets in the game
ever and this last set it included a
bunch of pavilions and archways which
look very similar to the ones that we've
got in park text and I think because of
that I really like to use these things
and I really like to use them especially
for stations I'll try and pull up a
picture over here in case you're
wondering what these things look like so
you could see what they look like so you
can see that they are super similar to
the park tech ones and if you go back to
old roller coaster tycoon 3 videos from
around 2010 everybody is using these
things to build stations with them so I
guess that's what I tend to do a lot of
in my videos as well in any case it's
time to move on to a different area and
leave the floorless coaster behind us
and start to build a girl our
Eurofighter and I was wondering for a
while if I wanted to build a Eurofighter
I had the space and money to build a
hyper coaster which is something that
you don't do very often in Scenario play
but you know I figured that the theme
would fit mostly a Eurofighter coaster
especially something like takabisha
which is a coaster in fuji-q highland in
japan which is a park that i have a vlog
of on my computer that i still haven't
finished editing and i've been there
over a year ago right now which is a bit
embarrassing maybe I'll get to that one
day but yeah it's a park in Japan it's
really well known for having some of the
most thrilling coasters in the world it
has tech abhi show which has the
steepest drop in the world it has total
Dumbo which is the fastest launched in
the world it doesn't quite hit the
highest speed it's definitely up there
with the fastest coasters in the world
but the thing that makes it so special
is that it hits it's ridiculous speed in
I think it goes 180 kilometers of
something like that in about 1.6 seconds
something like that it's it's an insane
launch nothing compares to it and then
it also has a Jamaica which is I believe
the biggest 4d coaster in the world and
also absolutely insane but I was mostly
interested in takabisha which i think is
a bit underrated in the roster of
coasters that the park has even though
they're all pretty ridiculous it's like
a bishop I think is a coaster that does
almost everything a coaster can do it
has a launch it has a lift hill it has
all kinds of different elements
including the super unique banana roll
and what it also does is it has a barrel
roll right at the start of the right so
that's something that you can find back
in this coaster I didn't feature and
launched because well we can't and I
also made it a little bit smaller than
takabisha because it has to fit in the
scenario after all and even though it
might not look too much like takabisha
actually overall what mostly inspired me
was the way that it moves from one
unique elements into the other it's just
lots of inversions followed up by other
inversions one after the other and
that's why I really like about the
coaster it has a really cool sort of
momentum to it a very cool rhythm to the
different elements which i think is
pretty underrated I really like it for
that reason and this coaster does a sort
of similar thing we start off with the
Beyond vertical drop not quite as steep
as teka Bish's but definitely beyond
vertical they're into zero-g roll into a
Cobra roll
and then a sort of Stangel dive I
suppose it would be and then into this
weird elements with the corkscrew and a
half roll into a dive loop and finally a
corkscrew so lots of different
inversions after the after each other
there all of them are different than the
one before it and all of them are taking
them the inversion at a very similar
speed so that's the sort of design
philosophy I suppose it's a commission
that went into this ride
as for the color scheme it's a bit more
colorful a lot of the coasters so far in
the park I've been a bit bleak and a bit
grey so I thought it'd be nice to have a
very bright blue color for this one and
moving into this area also again new
colors for the paths and a sort of new
approach to how the paths look this
thing is also definitely not going to be
very efficient
there's no block breaks in the middle of
the ride and these Eurofighter cars are
quite small so it's not the best choice
if you want to make money but as you can
see money is flowing in a way faster
than I can ever wish to spend it so I'm
already way too rich on this scenario
also quite far ahead in terms of the
years it's been taking me quite a while
to build this one I guess oh yeah and
also here's the indoor barrel roll I
should probably talk about that a little
bit it's a bit of a typical thing for
Euro fighters and girls lowery coasters
in general to have an indoor barrel roll
now I'm not going to spoil any coasters
because a lot of times this is sort of a
surprise elements for first-time riders
so I know let's tell you which coasters
have this indoor barrel roll but it's
it's definitely something that a lot of
indoor girl our coasters have so I
figured I would also put it on this
coaster it doesn't really make too much
sense per se from an in-game perspective
because I'm not going to do a POV where
you can actually see the inside of the
building but I think it works as
something which just makes the coaster
make a bit more sense if you're looking
at it from above it also gives me an
excuse to build another building and
help to add to the overall sci-fi vibe
of the park so yeah I think that works
quite well but the coaster in the end
you know it doesn't really have to do
of making money I figured given how many
guests the coast was so far brought in
that if I built one more major coaster
as well as two extra flat rides I'd be
able to reach the guest goal for this
scenario and I'd be able to finish the
park with this coaster I was actually
thinking for a while that I might build
another coaster there's something really
big but in the end the park is already
getting pretty full and it's also
getting pretty laggy I have to admit
there's a lot of different pieces in
here and a lot more guests than the
scenarios so far so I was getting done
with this thing it wasn't too bad but it
was definitely getting more annoying on
the recording side of it so definitely
want to move on after this coaster but I
don't want to stop yet I do wanna give
it a bit of a nice theming so the
station is pretty simple didn't want to
do too much with that it's a bit of an
old looking station actually it looks
very similar to sort of 60 70s
rollercoaster stations except with much
more sci-fi materials so it's almost got
a sort of retro sci-fi look to it but
yeah that's that's not so important I
guess although I I think it does work if
you're building sci-fi parks to just
make it really absurd or try and go for
a retro sci-fi because if you go for a
futuristic idea of you know what is
deemed futuristic at the time it's still
gonna aged horribly so if you look for
instance at the original Tomorrowland of
Disneyland's you can clearly tell that
that's what the past would think the
future would look like so if you want to
try and stop your sci-fi things from
aging really badly it really helps to
make it very surrealistic or make clear
that it's some sort of past idea of what
the future would be like something like
the steampunk for instance what's also
kind of funny I think is a during this
playthrough I did this thing which I
sometimes do and try to listen to very
thematic music that works to the theme
of what I'm doing so I was actually
looking into sci-fi themed
music albums for this one ended up doing
a little bit of discovery doing a little
bit of David Bowie Ziggy Stardust of
course but also Janelle Monae and God I
forgot the name recently but just lots
of sci-fi albums and I don't know if it
really particularly gets me into the
mood but I just think it's fun to
explore music of a particular type
whenever I'm doing a certain themed park
so yeah that's that's what I was
listening to doing these things for
those who don't know I just like to put
up some music while I record time lapses
oh right that's a Deltron 3030 was also
something that I listened to a lot for
this playthrough and it just I don't
know it's it's nice too it's a nice
opportunity to discover music as well
because I like to do something else
while I'm listening to music but
definitely not something that takes too
much of my focus and on the other hand I
like to do something while I'm recording
videos but something that doesn't take
too much of my focus away so what I
built doesn't look terrible and for me
listening to music is just the best way
to play these kinds of games so yeah
that's a bit of I guess interesting
information about me in any case decided
to finish up the queue very simply by
meandering underneath the coaster track
I wasn't really intending to do that at
first but then I discovered that I sort
of wiggled my way into a dead-end with
the low to the ground coaster track that
was moving everywhere so I had to find
some way to move underneath that and
also I put all of these little roofs not
at different random places they are at
all the places where the path is very
close to or right underneath the coaster
track just to you know protect against
loose items that fall off the coaster it
happens a lot to hats and phones and
cameras so that's always a concern with
roller coasters and finally it was time
to spruce up the place with some foliage
no pun intended
well actually maybe I did intend that
maybe I made that pun too many times
already anyway
I think the foliage is one of the things
one of the key things actually pulls
this pike together because usually I
like to have different parts of the park
have slightly different foliage but in
this case I wanted to have the same
trees everywhere because the park is
already very much all over the place and
everything looks very different so
having the weird surrealistic sort of
alien foliage at least be the same
everywhere
gives it a bit of can I guess continuity
continuity there there we go so I think
that works alright even though the
foliage for me it's still something that
I do know is quite controversial when I
originally made Protoss in rollerCoaster
Tycoon 3 I ended up getting a lot of
mixed reactions from the for the foliage
and spent a lot of time tinkering with
the different colors of trees but in
this case I think the different hues of
pink and purple and red and green work
quite alright with each other I didn't
actually pull that from an existing
color scheme but yeah I just thought
this worked best so I'm actually gonna
leave it like it is in any case that's
it for the scenario so let's take a look
around and check out all of the coasters
and stuff that I did in the final part
of this time-lapse alright so here's the
park I'm gonna try my best to keep my
voice okay during this recording I've
got my water right here I'm also sorry
about the some of the distortion on the
last vocal clip I only realized that the
end of that entire recording that the
gain on my mic was a bit too high and I
honestly didn't want to go back to it
because it was already the secondary
recording of that part and I wasn't
really feeling like recording that at
the time so I'm sorry about that I'll
try to actually pay more attention to
that I can at least see right now in OBS
that my mic was clipping when I was
recording a little bit of a test audio
so that's something to keep in mind in
any case this is the park and it might
be a little bit laggy on you guys side
although I do have to say it's less
laggy than I expected it to be
also yeah there was a comment a long
time ago that technically it's not lag
it's just stuttering frame rates which
is totally true it's not actually online
it's just what I suppose that's the
gamer term for it more or less at this
point but yeah the frame rates I think
is pretty decent it's not even doing too
bad so none of the rights have actual
names but I still want to do a quick
tour of the different coasters and then
just show some different points of
interests in the park I'm just gonna
wait for the Eurofighter to finish its
little round over here I never quite
fixed the timing on this thing I'm
actually gonna have to put the minimum
waiting time on about 35 seconds as well
I think because it stalls on the left
hill here which is not the the best
thing to look at in any case let's zoom
in on this car right here and see what
the layout is like so yeah first drop
this is all pretty standard fare for
Eurofighter even if this is quite a
large Eurofighter it's not as big as
takabisha but definitely a similar size
on Cobra rolls by the way you always
want to make sure that it's a little bit
banked between those two corkscrews into
a sort of Stangel dive into this crazy
element over here and a dive loop and
the overall pacing I'm actually quite
happy with even on the airtime Hill you
never really get super ridiculous
airtime on Eurofighter coasters but you
do have some every now and then and
that's basically the ride so yeah I'm
pretty happy with this thing actually
I'm gonna see how well this actually
works as a blueprints because it does
have that sort of gimmicky barrel roll
at the start over here and it's also
slightly build on a on a slope so not
quite sure how well that's going to work
out but I definitely want to look into
it
now the surrounding area is pretty
simple I just noticed I didn't actually
open the 4d cinema so let's just do that
right away that shouldn't work just like
that people are absolutely killing
themselves on this right I would never
want to write one of these things I
think I don't know it all just depends
on how comfortable the restraints are
but a lot rides on the restraints here
now also in the meantime I'm reaching
the goals and
I wasn't quite sure if I would because I
do need to have an experiences rating of
at least 70% and it's a little bit close
to that but uh yeah it looks like the
park is actually doing okay in that
regard so I'm just gonna save real quick
and then get back to it - look at this
go oh wait a second I do want to get
into the camera here so yeah there we go
let's launch and see what this looks
like we're kind of reached the goals in
the meantime but that doesn't disturb
the POV nice awesome so we get to see
that coaster riding through the confetti
there's not a lot of people on this
train actually it's empty except for one
guy anyway
cool little airtime Hill over here which
is just some flow to airtime
realistically but I think it works
alright and into the final transition
which is surprisingly smooth I'm still
impressed by how smooth that curves that
curve and the pullout into the final
brake run ends up working so pretty cool
coaster actually this is my favorite
from the entire scenario I think I just
like the red and white color scheme
that's going on here as well as the very
picturesque layouts I think this would
be one that would be really interesting
to watch from the paths with that sort
of flying elements over this main
pathway and the first top hat with these
surrounding structures I think it would
be a nice coaster in terms of skyline
that's definitely something that I
always like to look out for as well so
we've got this thing bit of some
interesting queue shenanigans going on
for this coaster I lately find it pretty
fun to mess around with the different
glass pieces and give them different
colors and try and make different shapes
out of them didn't really get anything -
perspective cooler done so far but
especially as you get to a bigger scale
I think there's a lot of interesting
stuff to be done with that but next I
really want to follow the floorless
coaster and I'm actually kind of curious
how well it's doing it's making a decent
bit of money there just because these
things are so incredibly efficient
so yeah let's follow this train should
be able to get
going straight from the left over here
yeah the timing on this thing on the
break runs is actually quite good and on
the launch coaster I'm actually using
the block break timing to make sure that
the coaster stops just before the launch
which I think works out quite nicely as
well so a very simple sort of standard
floorless coaster layouts starting off
with a loop into I think it was an
Immelmann yeah and then into a corkscrew
actually it's a little bit smaller and
shorter than most real-life flawless
coasters would be but the layouts just
worked really well like this so I wanted
to keep it this way so yeah that's that
right god I kind of want to wait until
the rain is over to actually point out
some other things but now I think it'll
be fine something that I also did here
and there to try and make this park feel
more connected even though everything
just looks completely different and I'm
trying new things with new pieces in
every section is to have some colors
that you know are the same in terms of
Exxon's and stuff in different parts of
the park so the the same kind of orange
is used on the trim of this building as
well as the umbrellas and some of the
details of the station and cue line of
this coaster and even this pavilion of
this coaster over here so that's just
one of those details that I think sort
of pull the park together a little bit
more looking around for some similar
things right there's the color red in
this area with the red cue line the the
red flat right and the red trims on this
building so a lot of very similar colors
over there as well over here have also
got some of those red trims coming back
as well some blues here and there so
yeah overall I'm trying to give
everything slightly different colors but
if you zoom out you'll be able to sort
of see that there's a different sort of
color palettes for different areas like
they've all got their own sort of look
we've got the area over here with the
florists coaster this sort of Plaza with
in the middle the Gravitron alongside
the launch coaster over here then the
starting area has its own sort of look
and then finally the the door
red paths over here at the Eurofighter
coaster which sometimes the coloring is
also just very much related to the ride
so for this coaster for instance we've
got the turquoise track which I believed
her choice doesn't really come back
anywhere else in this area but the very
dark bright pink of the supports come
back in the the walls on the bottom of
the station building as well as some
parts of the queue actually the covered
parts and also this pavilion at the
start of the entrance so especially when
it comes to coasters and their own
surroundings and pathways and the queues
and station buildings I always like to
bring back the colors of the coaster
itself in a very subtle way so yeah
that's just a little bit of tips I
suppose these certain things in the end
I I'm pretty happy with this park
honestly it worked out a little bit
better than expected but I do have to
say doing something like this isn't
entirely my strong suit and if I ever
get to build another sci-fi park like
this being in a scenario or sandbox I
would I'll probably prefer to get back
to the approach of trying to make
everything in the same style and trying
to make it fit into one certain
structure or theme or something like
that this is a little bit too over the
place I think all over the place I mean
and come to think of it did I ever do a
POV of the spinning coaster I don't
think I really did in any case let's
just follow this thing around it's
pretty simple but it's definitely the
right that has the largest amount of
interaction with the other parts of the
park all of the different paths and
areas a bit of a journey actually across
the park and also the only real family
ride I was kind of thinking that I was
missing a family coaster in this park
but yeah I didn't want to build another
family coaster and spend a lot of time
on that I at that point when I was
considering it I thought it would be
much more fun to build the Eurofighter
instead so there's that the
just gonna have to write this thing it's
not actually that intense to be honest
but yeah that is basically the park so I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode even
though it wasn't quite the usual fare in
terms of contents and my commentary and
let's try to make it better again next
time
speaking of next time I'm pretty much
done with this thing so we can quit and
see what else we're gonna get all right
so we finished Nova Labs we can play it
in the sandbox now and I don't think
we're gonna get anything else oh yeah
actually we do which is gonna skip
straight ahead to whatever is gonna be
there okay so I am a little bit curious
I'm not gonna play this in the next
episode but okay okay that's Adventure
Island all right good to know so that's
one that I made but we'll get to that
later for now I want to focus on
archipelago adventures which is one of
these nodes that I believe this is one
of the scenarios that Joshua made not
quite sure but actually I'm pretty sure
so out cycle that next time it's going
to be a pretty challenging one and the
terrain is definitely going to be very
different from everything that we've
seen so far so I think it'll be very
interesting so yeah hope you guys
enjoyed and I'll see you next time